logan Paul's YouTube red show got
revived why are people so mad over the
grain avatar guy and it's better how the
staff this is much more I'm Yuri border
and you're watching porn
[Music]
long shelled Logan Paul movie sequel
launches today on YouTube premium hooray
Yatta this man I've been looking forward
to the thinning - I wonder what's gonna
happen is he gonna get thinner so a lot
of people at least in my Twitter feed or
anyone mentioning PewDiePie kind of
pointed out the hypocrisy in this if you
guys remember Logan Falls movie got
canceled or put on hold as a reaction
from YouTube after he showed the dead
body in the forests of Japan so people
are saying well you brought back his
show then you need to bring back scare
PewDiePie PewDiePie did a dumb veggie
joke and got his show cancelled logan
film then real dead body and got his you
to show a sequel if we're gonna release
logan paul's youtube read show then
where the heck is scare PewDiePie season
2 and following this news as far as my
person will take away i feel like a ton
of people are expecting me to just rip
into youtube and logan paul but i really
don't know how to feel anymore i mean
personally I'm more interested in what
someone like PewDiePie feels about this
is YouTube read series on that note as
of recording this video I haven't seen
Felix comment publicly about this okay
well if YouTube is gonna do this where
is season 2 of scare PewDiePie sorry
what do I think well I'm just Gloria
Borger Tina Fey is not gonna make a
response okay but me Gloria Borger wait
amber Who am I poppy Harlow Gloria quit
I forgot it's gonna give my response if
you guys remember you to put logan
paul's show on hold ten days after the
controversy
it took youtube ten days to come up with
this assessment that well we're probably
gonna have to cancel his show because
otherwise we look like a bunch of fools
because we canceled pretty pice show
like that i mean i was asleep when they
cancelled my show I cancelled just as
the news broke that was there was no
question about it
it took nowhere hesitation on that one
but with that with Logan Paul show it
was like ten days after and it's on hold
so it was under certain whether he would
come out or not it was due to be
released this year so I think it's only
natural that you have a lot of people
saying just found out that YouTube is
moving forward with the second season
alone Paul's
YouTube premium series ten month after
the suicide forest video so we can
assume PewDiePie will be getting season
2 of hit series release as well a
question mark I haven't seen any
indication of that happening whatsoever
I've asked about it I don't know maybe
this opens up for new discussions but
it's kind of amazing how a
billion-dollar company can be so inept
at leadership if you want to be taken
seriously you need to apply the same
rules for everyone
you can't just nitpick whatever you want
then you just look like an idiot
and people will undoubtedly be upset and
I think that's what's happening here so
with or without controversy the thinning
was coming out this year no matter what
it was due to be released this year and
it got released this year so whatever
the controversy was involved had no
effect I mean what did it change there
to get delayed a month over two months
with what there's no effect there
whatsoever scare PewDiePie was finished
we finished shooting it it's ready it
needs to be edited but that's it YouTube
made a response to the fact that they
released the show the thinning Logan
Paul's show saying that the entire cast
and crew worked extremely hard to
complete this film last year I think
this is a good point because scary to
fight we didn't work hard let's get
really but anyway in fairness to all of
them and the fans who have been asking
for the sequel we decided to release the
thinning the New World Order in fairness
thank you YouTube for your fairness so
apparently yeah scare PewDiePie we
didn't work hard and
alright that our fans have not been
asking for it whatsoever so I believe
this fairness but then again they're not
wrong it isn't fair
I mean this is why when Logan pulls
controversy broke despite me clearly I
don't like him I said I don't think his
show should be canceled and I meant that
because you know punished Logan for what
he did and punished me and for my
mistakes
but to punish everyone involved on this
project I mean these parts are so
massive it just doesn't make sense it
just isn't fair to everyone else
involved I do understand that there is a
difference between Logan's project
called the thinning it's not Logan Paul
the thinning you know it's my show it's
PewDiePie so maybe that's why they
reacted to it differently maybe that's
why they're doing this a different
treatment maybe it's because I joked
about Jews and that's some more
sensitive topics then topic then showing
a dead body Bros someone making suicide
I think that's probably what some people
think at least I think maybe YouTube
reacted a bit paced hasting Lee is that
a word hastily a bit too quickly when
deciding to cancel scare PewDiePie it
was their most successful you to show as
far as I know I personally believe in
the YouTube read program it's been
criticized so much but it's a great idea
I really do think it has a lot of
potential I don't think they realized
that if they did this to me they're
gonna have to do it to everyone else
because they clearly don't want to do
that obviously they did Logan clearly
got a different treatment here I think
that's pretty safe to say to be honest
good for him
I'm happy for it I stand by what I said
I don't think his show should have been
canceled and I'm glad it got released it
is disappointing from my perspective
seeing that I got different treatment
it's kind of annoying I think YouTube is
sitting in the same boat you know I'm
happy that Logan's got released but I'm
happy that my didn't and I'm sure you
two feel the same way in a sense I don't
know where we go what do you guys think
better help me review better help if you
guys checked out my video and better
help thank you guys for all the amazing
support on that video honestly I got
some of the nicest comments I've ever
gotten on the video I it was the most
stressful video I've ever uploaded you
know I went so I thought it was like not
a big deal you know I can do this but it
was stressful I'm not gonna lie I didn't
think it would be but regardless
basically to run it down quickly better
help was an online therapy service it
had a lot of questionable things with it
I pointed those out and the fact that
youtubers were paid per person signing
up to this service to me was deeply
concerning per person that they get to
sign up for better help $200 that's a
lot of money just get a thousand people
signing up you just made $200,000
ever since that video better help has
removed all their video testimonies from
their website which I thought was
interesting I don't think it really
matters there was this whole thing about
Julian says which was clearly just a guy
hired to say the testimony you need stay
alone
Jesus you needn't stay alone Julian says
that better help calm is a reliable
online platform to receive there
[Music]
communicate with a licensed psychologist
from home than at an office the center
button also has an answer so people
found Julian's or Julian sense or Rob's
pens fiber page where he does
testimonials big props to rob because he
he had a great approach to it I saw his
response actually you know I haven't
really done anything wrong here yeah
it's embarrassing and I agree I do have
a really creepy smile at the end so
better help made a response to all these
allegations and they made it the same
day I recorded my video that's why I
never got a chance to talk about it so
it seems only fair that I talk about it
now
especially the duty
the fact that they've been tweeting this
frantically to anyone caught commenting
about better help on Twitter hey you may
be misinformed hey you baby mr. form
read this so let's read it let's go
through it it was written by the CEO of
better help on medium and I think he
went to read it as well
hi I'm better helps found right here on
my thoughts they basically go on to say
how great better help is how very few
companies can truly say that their value
is enable is to enable a better life and
just that they're doing a great job
basically strangely enough they are
funny enough I guess they bring up the
drama between King star and felt virtual
fight with another youtuber host who has
several million followers sort of
pivoting it as this was all a reaction
to drama people just wanting drama and
that's what costs for it
I didn't mention anything about fill in
my video because I didn't want it to be
about drama I wanted to just be clear
what my criticism of better help was
they also go on to say that they have a
long process of verifying their
therapist and they can assure that their
therapist are legit but their terms of
service clearly stated completely
differently and they basically said it
was up to you to determine whether you
were talking to an actual therapist or
not this one says that they don't
guarantee the verification of the skills
degrees qualifications certification
credentials competence or background of
any counselor with better help you'll be
talking to professionals just be aware
that it's your responsibility to
determine whether they are or not you
could be talking to some guy in your
Ukraine sending you sad smiley emojis
they also bring up all these conspiracy
theory allegations which I understand
there weren't a lot of weird
conspiracies going on while trying to
uncover better help I didn't bring up
any of it I mean the biggest one was
probably the Julian says one which I
brought up because it was funny then
they finish off with the ultimate level
of smugness saying that ironically over
this interesting week we've had a record
number of new members who signed up
congratulations better health so they
basically don't care so what they did
dress was that why do they market that
they cost $65 per week but they still
charge monthly this is what it says when
they ask you to enter your credit card
information free trial try the service
seven days no risk
look $0 if you're one of the companies
that can truly say that their value is
to enable a better life then why do you
need to you see sort of learning
business methods to get people to sign
up for your subscription why can't you
just say the amount that you will charge
you why can't you just be honest and
clear about that why this level of
deception involved second why do you
mark it still here as a replacement for
in-office counseling well in your Terms
of Service you still say that you are
not a complete substitute for
face-to-face examination look how much
money you save by not using our
therapist I've been getting a ton of
messages from actual therapists or
people that I have gone through therapy
who said that this sort of idea of
online therapy is ridiculous you need to
properly sit down face-to-face with a
person to get the job done to get to the
core of the issue obviously I'm not an
expert why are people saying that they
got diagnosed from better health
they also replied to the bad reviews on
the website saying that they can't vouch
for their authenticity funnily enough
that's what I said in my video I can't
vouch that the bad reviews aren't
authentic but then you can either vouch
for the positive ones it's such an on
argument so I think what a lot of people
wanted to know is better help a scam and
I watch this video from youtuber log
which was really interesting so with all
these different issues and believe me
there are more and more provisions that
I just don't want to go through that are
just funny and make no sense and are
indicative of the fact that somebody did
a cut-and-paste over off of other
people's websites why do I say it's not
a scam it's because I've dealt with so
many of these kind of platforms and I
tell you they make no money here these
platform makes pennies on the dollars
and as a result if you want to scan
people this is like the worst business
model through which to scam people there
are far far better ways to do it online
basically explaining that there
extremely poorly written they most
likely just copied and pasted a lot of
pieces from it and they probably just
wanted to save money so while they
legally might not be a scam they
certainly have a lot of questionable
things about them to be honest I think
it's entirely possible that they have
good intentions but the difference
between their what they're saying in
their Terms of Service and how they
market it to me shows that they're very
responsible at least and that it shows
me as well where their focus is they've
clearly spent a lot more time on how to
market and sell their product I'm not
personally against a company like better
help existing even if I'm skeptic
whether online therapy works or not or
if it's the best way I understand that
that's a service that a lot of people
can't actually benefit from but clearly
it's not positive for everyone
and combine that with the fact that
youtubers are promoting this getting
$200 per sign up with the topic of
mental help to me that's very very
concerning maybe that's a personal thing
because I hate referrals I understand
that they are a common practice in in
business and even therapy but to compare
that with youtubers telling their fans
to sign up I think it's completely
different because they have licenses and
policies $200 per fans with mental
health issues or struggling with mental
health I don't like it
but like I said in the video at the same
time I don't think these youtubers knew
what they were promoting I don't think
they looked into it too deeply
I even had youtubers that I showed in my
video thanking me for showing the issues
we'd better help and it was nice to see
that reaction now I also want to mention
that I felt like it was important that I
showed how youtubers promoted this
service it was a big part of the whole
thing for me and he goes through the
Terms of Service and he points out a lot
of questionable things which is fine and
he doesn't like the service and he
raises good points about it but the way
that he presented my involvement in it I
thought was a little misleading and a
little out of context
and it made it look like I was way more
involved with this company and then I
was it was it was gotten so bad that it
was basically either stop making videos
or disappear also this video is
sponsored by better help more
information about that at the end of
this video so basically I I agree I cut
this very poorly I thought it was clear
that this was Bobby's video and not
Ethan's video but even then I wanted to
be clear my point was not to drag these
youtubers I'm sure Bobby had good
intentions while pushing this service
because if you think you are promoting a
service that is helping other fans and
you get paid at the same time I mean
that seems pretty win-win to me but
that's clearly not necessarily the case
but I felt like it was necessary to show
these youtubers how they was promoted in
the video but that clearly led to a lot
of drama and controversies and I think
this is a good lesson for everyone look
more carefully into what you're
promoting to your fans especially if you
are paid per person using that product
that being said check out my new merch
everybody
that's right meme review YouTube's
favorite merch actually it's Peter pies
March I'm just Gloria Borger
I mean Papa Harlem showing this much
it's only available for four more days I
mean three more days max note PBC
trending why is Twitter ban 1500
accounts and what are NPCs you've
probably seen this meme it's been
practically everywhere I've been
debating do I show this on pureness or
me me review why would I wear this is
belong I love how penis and meme review
is just but never been closer together
me and PewDiePie have been discussing
this but I feel very passionate about
this story they started from a post
online saying that I have a theory that
there are only a fixed quantity of souls
on planet Earth that cycles continuously
through reincarnation however since the
human growth rate is so severe the soul
is extra walking flesh piles around us
as NPCs or ultimate Norma
people who are autonomously follow group
things and social trends in order to
repair convincingly human I called these
people NPCs because when you talk to
them they just say the same every time
Trump is bad just be yourself
sports pout the new Adele song oh my god
if you get a discussion with them it's
always the same buzzwords I love this
mean because from a spiritual or
philosophical standpoint it makes 100
percent Saints okay you have all these
feel-good quotes saying like there's
just as many stars in the galaxy as
there are people that have lived on
earth in our galaxy well what about the
new ones then huh we got more and more
people living NPC theory proven thank
you very much we are pew news here we
report on the facts the facts the truth
and nothing but the truth
hello I am a comedian on television if
you disagree with my politics you must
be mentally yield diversity is our
strength so a lot of people that had a
problem with this meme which it just
makes it even funnier the fact that
people actually give a damn about this
stupid meme it blows my mind I think
that's the main reason why it's funny if
no one cared about this meme it wouldn't
be funny but people are saying that it's
dehumanizing Chad and PC only watches
Game of Thrones has seen every Marvel
movie and can't wait for the next Star
Wars wake up sheeple I've been telling
this for years Marvel movies are trashed
you like Marvel your neighbors -
unfortunately this this golden mean this
meme dipped ankle has gotten tainted by
politics which of Donald Trump core
values do you support you have left and
right basically saying you're an empress
e'er you're an MPC insult XE so trap
hahaha a New York Times reporting on
this what is the MPC the pro Trump
Internet's favorite insult Jesus Christ
are these Russian BOTS probably not
probably 2018 everybody the beams are
there in a strange place I got it
New York Times even asking themselves
aren't you giving these trolls attention
they're seeking by writing about them in
the New York Times yes you are 100%
giving these people more power by
talking about it but they can't help
themselves they just can't help
themselves it's so satisfying to
symbolize something as an evil evil
thing to most people it's just a meme no
one thinks about it as any further so
rest in peace and peace II mean this one
you can't blame on me review okay I had
nothing to I mean I never have anything
last but not least Shane Dawson finished
his series on Jake Paul I'm only bring
this up because I criticized that one
episode otherwise I thought it was a
great series I really really enjoyed it
I have a lot of respect for Shane like
like like like like mine's like like
like they're really pushing the boundary
on um videos in general I think it's
it's really impressive and inspiring
what they're doing so that's why for
this week's shout out week I'm shouting
out Jake he clearly needs a shout out
for me guys so I don't know if you guys
have heard of a Shane Dawson you
probably never heard of him small
youtuber needs a shout out
no but for real I I meant what I said
and especially with me criticizing one
of the episodes just cuz I criticize
something doesn't mean I hate that
person or have some personal vendetta
with it or whatever to me it's very
different and I think the same thing
goes with the better health stuff you
know I make criticizing youtubers or
stuff in general but I don't personally
hate someone or whatever I really
special II enjoyed the last episode by
the way hearing Jake speak so eloquently
a was saying is it wonderful to hear
Jake like like I just like like like
even with Erica I like leave like you in
those video I appreciate all the support
consider coming a sponsor if you want to
and by the March that's probably the
best way to support your channel it's
really I gotta go goodbye to just fine
[Music]